- Carson is the dog, and I am
the cat in our relationship.
He's like, love me, love
me, love me, love me,
and I'm like, oh, I'll think about it.
- Not quite yet.
We ended up settling upon this place,
and we walked in and immediately,
we saw the tall ceilings.
It had an actual place
we can park outside,
and I was like, oh my,
take my money please.
But we have, as you can
see, a lot of space to fill.
- I'm a little bit bohemian when it comes
to my personal style.
I know that Carson's not as
bohemian as I am (laughs).
- If we have a huge room,
we're gonna need a big TV.
- How big a TV do you want?
- Um, is there really a
size that's big enough?
(upbeat drum music)
Search for the couch first, obviously.
- Yep, modern couch.
- Modern couch.
- Look at that one, wow!
You could seat like 10 people on that.
- That looks really nice.
- Let's make a bid.
- Let's chat with Nicholas Y.
- Nicholas, why don't you
want your couch anymore?
It's beautiful.
I think he's going to love that message.
- Standing desk, how about this one?
- That is cool, I don't
even care where she lives.
I want it.
- Maybe like a floor lamp?
- [Miranda] Oh, that's cool.
- I got a bunch of messages.
- Wilson the cat.
- We can put an emoji.
How about the drooling
puppy that says how much?
- Okay, perfect.
I think that's everything.
- We like gotta start to
pick some of this stuff up.
We're gonna start all
the way up in Studio City
to get your standing desk, and then
we're just gonna make a big loop around
going to West Hollywood, Koreatown,
Mid-Wilshire, Miracle
Mile, and then finally
back to Hollywood, and then to our house.
So, it's a long day, but
we do have one of the vans
following us, so we can
put all the big things
in there, make it really easy.
- And you're driving,
so my job's really easy.
- It is, you could just sit
here and do nothing, I guess.
- No, I'll probably keep shopping.
- No, we have so much.
- Just a couple more things.
- We are so close to
being over our budget.
- I'm gonna look for like one more lamp.
Let's look at throw pillows.
I'm just gonna look for plants (laughs).
(screams happily) It's so cool!
(upbeat music)
(uptempo drum music)
- All right, off to get the couch.
- Yeah, and then we're close to home.
- But we may need to run
one little more stop.
- Oh, the TV.
- It's awesome.
- It looks just like the real chair.
Let's see, oh!
- Do you have ten?
- Oh, he comes and asks for change.
Let's see, you're lucky.
- Hey! (laughs) All right, man.
- You buy a couch.
- Hello, couch.
- We get the rug, and
that leaves literally
just enough to get your TV.
- It does?
- Just enough.
Oh my gosh, you're so
happy right now (laughs).
- What are all the letters?
- Four K, HD,
two 40 HZ
- LED, yes!
(upbeat bongo music)
- [Couple] We did it!
- I'm honestly surprised
that we got it done.
Looking around at this room,
it has so much character.
Our previous furniture has
all been from big box stores,
and it is not nearly this charming.
- Everyone we interacted
with today was so nice.
- Yeah.
- And like, take their lightly-used stuff,
and now it's a part of
our home, and that's just
kind of awesome.
- And I'm shocked that
Carson hasn't mentioned this.
He got his TV.
- I got the TV!
(upbeat electric guitar music)